EU transport ministers will seek to  harmonize technical requirements for  vessels navigating through the EU s  canals and rivers to make inland  navigation in Europe safer ministers  will also discuss proposals to open rail  services to international competition so  that consumers can benefit from more  choice lower prices and new services  which are more efficient and consumer  friendly the council will also look at  new proposals to improve air passenger  rights and clarify the airline's  responsibilities when problems occur the  proposed changes aim to ensure that air  passengers have new and better rights to  Information care and rerouting when they  are stranded at the airport at the same  time better complaint procedures and  enforcement measures would be introduced  so that passengers can actually obtain  the rights they're entitled to